in order to defeat Trump Ron DeSantis
has to do some of the things Trump does
well he has to be entertaining he has to
attack Trump he has to be titillating
and salacious and Ron DeSantis is going
to have to figure out how it is a
horrible thing that on the one hand we
know that all of this is terrible for
the country the fact that this is how a
Republican primary is going to be fought
who can come up with the slickest
insults in the entire thing I would love
to change that I can't change that
and so when we are thinking through how
Republicans are going to choose their
nominee Democrats to a degree the same
thing but if Biden runs they're not
really going to be choosing it's going
to be Biden it's going to come down to
who can make their campaign as
entertaining and titillating as possible